it's a very tough world out there we
used to talk about a VUCA world volatile
uncertain complex and ambiguous now it's
a VUCA world on steroids the speed at
which things are happening is just
beyond what we have seen before the
growth is such that we're doubling
technical knowledge every two years this
is the time for people to step up this
is a time for people to say how do we do
something
[Music]
the MIT leadership style I think if we
were gonna characterize it it would be
let's get something done go out build
design invent and create something new I
think we really have to go beyond our
comfort zones and that's about taking
risk we want to solve big complex
problems then we have to necessarily be
in the discussions the negotiations
active learning it's not usually about
the technology it's usually about people
[Music]
it's sort of odd that we assume people
graduate after four years of college and
they're ready for the rest of their
lives it's simply not the case
they're gonna have to keep learning is
it just that you learn and then you sort
of regurgitate it at an exam or do you
learn so that you can actually do
something invent a product develop a new
system as the world changes we need our
systems of Education to deliver content
and abilities and skills and knowledge
that empowers people to take on new
challenges it is that ability that is
going to define the leaders of the
future
[Music]
you
[Music]